bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 6 à
7 on vient d'apprendre une terrible
nouvelle je suis bouleversée sous vos
pas rendre hommage jean pierre pernaut
nous a quittés et bien de vous quitter
je suis désolé pardon
c'est une fille voulait pas faire mais
d'apprendre son décès à l'instant et on
est tous sous le choc
jean pierre pernaut de la quitter on
fait une émission spéciale évidemment
tout à l'heure je suis désolé
nos pensées laurent devant son épouse
évidemment et c'est fou
je suis désolé
on l'aimé beaucoup il va tous nous
manquer à tous à toute la france le sait
jean pierre pernaut est parti ces années
sous le choc je suis désolé je suis
désolé
emilie le patient soit sa part mais moi
je suis vraiment combien de m'apprendre
je l'aimé beaucoup notre travail anses a
enfin bon jean pascal avait un bon soir
on va ici de faire une émission par nous
on rendra hommage évidemment cyril
l'aimé tant et tous les chroniqueurs
pour les bétons
je suis désolé